مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
هذا الموسم كان موسم الصدمات حتى الان
الصدمات كثيره امور كثيره كثيره حدثت في
الكره الاوروبيه عندي فاجات الجميع وتفوقت
في دورياتها وتقدمت في دوري ابطال اوروبا
انديه اخرى كان متوقع ان تكون منافسه على
اللقب هذا الموسم ان كان في الدوريات
المحليه او ان كان في دوري ابطال اوروبا
ولكن خيبت التوقعات وخلينا نبدا بالسلب
المره هاي لحتى نختم بالايجابي ويكون
ختامها مسك بدايه نبدا مع نادي يوفنتوس
اللي صرف هذا الموسم تقريبا 105 مليون
دولار على صفقات هي كيزه وبريمير المدافع
بالاضافه الى لاعب اخر اسمه كان بي اس
يعني ما كلف الفريق كثير هذه الصفقات كلفت
يوفنتوس 105 مليون دولار هذا الموسم
بالاضافه طبعا للتعاقد مع بول بوجبا وانخل
ديماريه
وبريدس بريديوس طبعا كان قادم على سبي
الاعاره ولكن بوغبا ودماريه كانوا صفقات
مجانيه ما حدث مع يوفنتوس هو امر يتعلق
بالدرجه الاولى
بقرارات المدرب بقرارات الهجري الهجري هو
اللي عليه اليوم الاكبر ان كان بالتحضير
للمباريات او ان كان باداره مباريات او ان
كان في قراءه ما يحدث داخل ارضيه الملعب
المشكل الاخرى ايضا اللي كانت واجهته
يوفنتوس بكل امانه هو اصابه عدد من
اللاعبين البارزين اللي كانوا ممكن يراهن
عليهم الاجر هذا الموسم وعم نحكي هون عن
بول بوغبا عن خالتي ماريا والاصابات
المتكرره على مدار الموسم يوفنتوس بعد
مرور الجولات يعني شفنا انه مش قادر ينافس
على لقب الدوري الايطالي شفناها بيخسر من
مكان بحيفا بيخسر
واحد بيودع دوري ابطال اوروبا من الدور
الاول ويتجاه الى الدوري الاوروبي بنسبه
كبيره
العوامل اللي ذكرناها كلها خلت يوفنتوس
فريق ما عنده ثقه بنفسه فريق غير قادر ان
يقدم اي شيء داخل ارضيه الملعب فريق فقير
فنيا وفقير على المستوى الابداعي ننتقل
الى الفريق الثاني وهو برشلونه برشلونه
اللي صرف هذا الموسم 153 مليون دولار على
صفقات طبعا الكل بيعرفها وكان في صفقات
غير هيك كثير ايضا جاءت على او بشكل مجاني
الى الفريق ولكن برشلونه هذا الموسم نعم
في الدوري الاسباني يقدم مستوى جيد الى حد
مارق من الخساره بالكلاسيكو بثلاثيه مقابل
هدف وحيد ولكن في دوري ابطال اوروبا
الفريق ودعى البطوله من الدوري الاول وخسر
من انتر ومن بايرن وبالتالي ما نجح انه
يعبر للدور الثاني وهي كانت ضرب قويه على
الصعيد المالي والاقتصادي والمعنوي للفريق
برشلونه الرئيسيه مشكله دهنيه او مشكله
نفسيه لانه الفريق من المباريات كبيره
وخصوصا بدوري ابطال اوروبا كان لما يكون
مسيطر متفوق ويتلاقى هدف
حسنا ينهار ويصير يتلقى هدف ثاني وثالث
والى اخره وبالتالي مشكله الفريق من
الواضح انه هي مشكله ذهنيه بالمقام الاول
المشكله الثانيه هي مشكله انسجام يعني لما
تجيب عدد كبير من اللاعبين على فريق واحد
بيصير صعب جدا انه انسجمه بسرعه بده وقت
لازم يحفظوا بعض لازم يتفاهموا لحتى يبلش
الانسجام يصير برشلونه هذا الموسم يعني
تركيز الان على بطوله الدوري بالدوري
الاوروبي اعتقد الفريق معنا طموحات كبيره
اذا جاء باللقب خير وبركه ما جابه بيكون
مش مشكله ولكن بالتاكيد واحده من اكبر
صدمات هذا الموسم بالانتقال الى الجانب
الايجابي وهنا سنتحدث مين عن نابولي
بالتاكيد نابولي هو واحد من اكثر الفرق
اللي فاجئت الناس هذا الموسم مع اسفلتي
المدرب الايطالي اللي طلع لاعبين مميزين
جدا هذا الموسم قدمه مستويات كبيره ان كان
في الدوري ابطال اوروبا وان كان في الدوري
الايطالي الفريق متصدر الدوري لفريق مريح
عن اقرب منافسين متصدر بمجموعته كان وتفوق
على ليفربول ونجح انه يتاهل كما تصدر
للمجموعه فاز على الليفر ب 4 اهداف مقابل
هدف وحيد في ملعب مارادونا بالجزء الاول
هذا الفريق متجانس جدا وعم بيلعب بشكل
ممتع جدا واداءه بالملعب رائع وفريق فعال
لذلك نابولي مع سباليتي كلام اخر هذا
الموسم واحدى اكبر المفاجات اثار
مفاجاه ساره الثانيه هي نيوكاسل يونايتد
وارسنال يعني مفاجاه سوا ارسنال متصدر
الدوري الانجليزي ارسنال هذا الموسم بدا
التنضج افكار ارتيتا بدا يجني او تجني
اداره ارسنال ثمار الصبر على هذا المدرب
فريق اصبح عضوي جدا يعني في حاله من
التجانس العضوي ما بين اللعيبه صاروا
متفاهمين متناغمين لدرجه كثير بعيده
والمدرب عارف اللعيبه واللعيبه عارف
المدرب وقادر يوظفها بالشكل المطلوب
وبالتالي شفنا هاي النسخه العظيمه من
ارسنال هذا الموسم طبعا ارتدت على مدار
السنوات الماضيه يشتغل على نقاط الضعف
وعزز نقاط القوه حتى شفنا ارسنال بالوضع
فيه نيوكاسل يونايتد لعمل صفقات مميزه على
مدار الموسم الماضي ولكن الموسم هذا ايضا
عزز صفقاته بالتعاقد مع ايزك كان عنده
تجديد بالفريق ببعض المراكز كان في تطوير
في في افكار نيوكاسل يونايتد شفنا ايضا
تعاقد مع سبينس كانت تعاقد ممتاز جدا هذا
الفريق اعتمد على الذكاء الموسم الماضي
وبدا يبني عليها هذا الموسم نيوكاسل
يونايتد يعني عم يمشي بشكل هندسي صحيح مئه
بالمئه لانه هذا الفريق عم يبني الهرم
القاعده الاساس وعم يبني على هذه القاعده
لحتى يصل لمرحله متقدمه بالدوري الانجليزي
الممتاز مش عم يتسرع مش عم بيعمل تعاقدات
كبيره مش عم يصرف مبالغ خياليه ابدا
الفريق ماشي خطوه بخطوه
عليك شايفين نيو كاسل في المركز الرابع
هذا الموسم في الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
حتى الان نهايه رح نحكي بعجال عن ليفربول
ليفربول اعتقد انه مع مرور الجولات راح
يكون افضل نعم بالتاكيد هي بدايه مفاجاه
بل صاعقه لجمهور ليفربول ولكن ليفربول
عنده الاسلحه عنده الادوات عنده المدرب
عند الروح عنده العقليه وبالتالي قادر انه
يرجع بالموسم الحالي يمكن ما ينافس على
قبب الدوري ولكن بالتاكيد راح يكون قريب
ومنافس على المقاعد المؤهله لدوري ابطال
اوروبا اما في بطوله دوري ابطال اوروبا
فليفربول لن يكون خصم سهل وخصوصا مع عوده
بعض المصابين مثل الكوناته وغيره من
اللاعبين اللي ممكن يعطوا اضافه ويقدم
لازم مع الفريق على مدار الاسابيع النقود
الان نحن امام توقف دوري لكاس العالم بعد
اسبوعين بعد ذلك رح نشوف شو راح يصير مع
هذه الفرق اللي ذكرناها بنهايه الموسم هل
ستبقى المفاجاه الايجابيه ايجابيه وهل
ستبقى الصدمات السلبيه سلبيه خلينا نشوف
بنهايه الموسم هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه لهم
بعض الصافره الى ان نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل
تكون بالف خير